the only way to make this a best-selling
book is to do the process properly your
role should be to open up every door
possible
and he said let the world close the
doors you're not meant to walk through
and walk through the ones that remain
open your company is giving you an
opportunity to learn to grow to test i
learned so much about digital and
strategy working at accenture that i
could never have got from reading a book
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best jay shetty
and my take on his top 10 rules for
success enjoy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one protect your
purpose
i realized that those three years and i
described it this way and the way you
said it that the three years being a
monk were being at school
and the last seven years since i've left
have been the exam
and i can genuinely say so far that
every tool that i have tested from my
monk toolkit works
and the biggest one or most most likely
the most powerful one that i felt is
there's a beautiful verse in the
manuscript
i talk about in the book
and it says that
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects you and what i mean by
that and i will broaden purpose to mean
what it needs to mean for anyone
listening
you have to protect
your strengths your calling your
passions your interests your skills you
have to protect them like a like a
precious jewel because the whole world
will come at you and tell you that it's
not a jewel the whole world will come at
you and tell you that it's worth nothing
and if you don't protect it it can't
protect your value back
and most of us as soon as we get
questioned we just chuck the jewel out
we just chuck it away and we go oh yeah
that wasn't worth anything
and then later on in life you realize
you threw away a precious jewel so i
love that verse because that's what i
was test being tested to do is i was
about to go sell myself short
and just go back into the world that i
came from and just chuck out that jewel
rather than like hey i learned all these
things i wanted to serve i became a monk
because i wanted to serve how can i
still serve how can i not just throw
that all out and pretend that it doesn't
matter and how can i apply the
discipline and the mentality and all of
the great skills because guess what when
surprise surprise no one wants to hire
someone with monk on their resume for
three years
and that's what i had
because they couldn't see the
transferable skills i had to see them so
they were thinking oh he's probably just
going to be really quiet in the office
right like what is he gonna do but i
knew that that choir was intuition i
knew that that choir was solitude not
loneliness i knew that that quiet was
the power that that ability to to to
read things just read in between the
lines to connect with people rule number
two interpret time most of us are asking
for things
that aren't even clearly linked to what
we are actually missing
and so i'll give an example of this i
have so many clients that i coach or so
many people that i work with where the
number one thing they want from their
partner is time
and like i wish my partner had more time
brendan i i wish they just gave me more
time now the amazing thing is me and
brendan are giving each other time right
now but what if i was like this the
whole time right what if brendan was
writing another best-selling book at
this time
and and we kind of talked but imagine we
did that the whole time it looks like
you're present there with them
but you're not when this is like this is
like a force field between you your
phone your your your task your thing i
love that time yeah that's so good this
could be a book this could be a
newspaper this could be email whatever
it is but it's interesting people say i
want more time and so people come back
from a weekend away
and then they'll go back to their pond
and be like i wish we spent more time
together and the other partners going
well we just went on going on a weekend
and they're thinking but no but you were
at the beach and i was with the kids and
it that wasn't so what are people really
asking for i've realized that over this
time people are asking for three things
when they're asking for time they're
asking for presents
they're asking for attention and they're
asking for intimacy that is what people
are actually asking for beautiful say
the word time and so we re we
misunderstand it rule number three open
up all possible doors we truly
have influence in our more than our
environment our environment affects us
for sure it plants seeds and weeds into
our life but there is still a choice
and and i think even if you feel there
isn't a choice
simply by accepting that there is it
means you have a chance to get out of
there and i think that's what because if
you don't accept that there is then
you're just gonna stay stuck correct
like there's been so many times in my
life and there's a beautiful
uh quote from edison
i don't think i said this last time but
if i did it's it's worth repeating he
said that when you believe you've
exhausted all options remember this you
haven't
and the reason why i love that is your
mind continuously feels stuck when it's
tried the obvious and that's why a lot
of creativity and focus studies say that
the first 10 ideas that come to your
mind are never the most interesting it's
when you get into the 11th idea that you
start breaking the pattern and so if
someone asks you oh what's your best
business idea your first 10 ideas are
probably not that innovative and so the
mind constantly gets stuck on that train
and you've got to keep reminding
yourself that there is another door
there could be another pathway i was
thinking about a piece of advice that so
one of my closest spiritual mentors who
is in london
i knew him since i was probably like 12
and probably went since i was 18. he
passed away this year from stage four
brain cancer
and he had brain cancer for about i
think like three
three four years now and so
i hadn't really had a real interaction
with him for the past few years because
every time i saw him he wasn't fully
functioning in his short-term memory his
long-term memory was there but his
short-term memory wasn't
and i remember speaking to him probably
about seven eight years ago
and asking him the question i said to
him you know i've got so many ideas
there's so many things i could do where
do i start
and he said this beautiful thing to me
he said you know what your role should
be to open up every door possible
and he said let the world close the
doors you're not meant to walk through
and walk through the ones that remain
open
and what i realize is most of us just
not opening up enough doors because we
think we only have the option of two
doors we look at life as binary zero and
one zero and one right it's just this
this or that and i mean i i think you'd
say this too about you and every guest
you've ever had on
i don't think life is ever this or that
it's like this that and that and maybe
that and that and there's always a gap
rule number four have a service mindset
let's take that salesperson
the more time that person spends
in empathy
their customers pain
and what the customer is really looking
for
the better they're going to be received
yes
so that service mindset always helps
because if you're thinking about and
this is what it comes and i said this to
my team when we were writing the book
and everything i was working on i said
if i sit here right now
and all i'm thinking about while i'm
writing the book is being a best-selling
book
then guess what i'm now not writing the
book i'm now living in the future and
i'm not living in the present and so the
only way to make this a best-selling
book is to do the process properly and i
don't think and this is what i do and
this is the only thing that's helping me
and again i go through all the time
after my first video went viral three
four years ago
i stopped creating because of the
pressure that i wouldn't be able to live
up to it
so i actually got scared because i was
like oh well what if the next video
doesn't do as well everyone's going to
think i'm tanking like you get into that
self-doubt and that self and i got into
that space where i was just thank you
for being honest about it yeah no really
like genuinely i didn't want to make a
video again because i was like this
video just got 40 million views like how
am i ever going to beat that right and
you get scared i'm not putting anything
out i'm just going to stop and then i
started to realize like well now i'm not
living in service anymore
i'm living out of ego and i'm living for
feeling a certain way and guess what i'm
not feeling better by not putting
anything out yeah and actually if i just
serve more i'll learn more so the way
i've made sense of it and there's a
verse in the gita that explains it too
is that you have full control
over the preparation
the
process and the practice
but you have no control over the
potential result
but all of those three things are the
result in and of themselves yes and so
if you get addicted to the process of
writing the practice of connecting with
the right people who can help share your
work and yeah like you said i am focused
on the process of making sure that the
most people in the world have the
opportunity to buy this book
but then if they choose not to buy it i
can't control that but i can control
making sure that it's in front of
everyone and that i believe in the
context and that to me is not attachment
that to me is not
ego that to me is
trying to live your best life i mean
like you know if you didn't just try if
you're like i read this book but who
cares yes i mean that's not service
either because the way i explain it and
i'm not i'm not claiming that this is it
and i'm not trying to say i'm it i'm
trying to say that
i think we all feel this way
if
you or me see an amazing movie we want
to tell everyone about it
if you read an amazing book you want to
tell everyone about it if you found the
cure to cancer you tell everyone about
it
for me i got to live an incredible life
thanks to these amazing teachers i met
i just want to tell everyone about it
like that's all i'm doing yes but i want
to tell everyone because of how powerful
it was
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you so
according to a study by carnegie mellon
university people with supportive
spouses are more likely to give
themselves the chance to succeed they
studied 163 married couples and found
that people with supportive spouses were
more likely to take on potentially
rewarding challenges those who accepted
challenges experienced more personal
growth happiness and psychological
well-being now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was just starting out i
had never released a video i hadn't
created any content and she was such an
important part of feeling supported on
that journey so whether you're in a
relationship whether you're dating
whether you're married or even if you're
single being supported by friends and a
strong community is important uh build
to serve by evan carmichael great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us that we can all
make a difference in the world thanks
evan
rule number five take advantage of every
opportunity so i end up creating this
social media role at accenture where i'm
creating all of this content i'm
learning how the biggest brands in the
world use social media i'm working with
executives on social media presence and
understanding twitter and linkedin and i
just get exposed to this incredible
world and that's where i get to learn
these skills it wasn't that like i never
created
you know viral content while i was at
accenture but it just started opening up
my mind to what was possible right it
was just like oh these are the tools
feeling comfortable with failure getting
it wrong it gave me a playground right
it gave me an opportunity and this is
what anyone who's listening in
to this right now watching this and
you're working at a company your company
is giving you an opportunity to learn to
grow to test i learned so much about
digital and strategy working at
accenture that i could never have got
from reading a book or or going to a
course or a seminar because it was there
like i was i was there with it every day
with a company that was 500 000 people
you know a global organization so
that's when when i hear that people are
dissatisfied with their jobs and their
companies my biggest question is have
you learned everything you possibly
could from that place
because the truth is you could find a
lot more meaning and passion in a place
that you don't want to be in
because you realize it could be the
answer and key to what you could do in
the future
and there is so much to gain yeah that's
a cool lens rule number six find your
strengths in life there are two aspects
that impact everything our thinking and
our actions
and i read a quote the other day that
was saying that the mistake we make is
that we either act without thinking or
we think without acting and i think
that's where most people are if you're
feeling stuck or you're like i'm not
sure what i'm doing right now you're
either doing too much thinking or you're
doing too much acting so you're just
doing a lot of stuff but you don't know
why you're doing it or you're just
sitting there procrastinating every day
and you're doing it so i'd say it's both
so the first thing i would say to you
is take a moment
and speak to three different people
speak to a family member a friend and a
colleague and ask them this one question
what strengths do i have what do you
think is my superpower what skills do
you think i bring emotional strong soft
hard whatever it is
do that first get that sense check
second thing for the next month take off
every weekend eight days because there's
eight
saturdays and sundays all together in a
month
and book a different course workshop
seminar online offline go to an event
shadow a friend go and spend time with
an aunt uncle who's doing the career you
want go and have eight new experiences
and after each of them sit with yourself
and ask yourself
did i like that yes or no
whether you like to or not ask yourself
why did i like it or why did i not like
it
and then ask yourself would i like to do
it again
and if the answer is yes yes yes guess
what go do it again and if the answer is
no no no don't do it again leave it out
but if you've had eight and this is the
problem we do that over a year we do
that over eight years and that's why
life feels slow and boring and lethargic
and stuck but it just in the next eight
days in a weekend just test eight new
things and you have just a great
experiment and the worst thing that will
happen is you'll find eight things that
you don't like but i guarantee you that
even if you have a sense of that
reflection in the beginning and and what
i don't get why we don't do this enough
is wow we do it with food and movies all
the time like you just
ed is such a kind man like i got here
slightly late because of traffic and
then he let me eat my lunch because i
wanted to be full of energy i i need to
find out where that place is because
it's local to here my my team got it
ordered for me it was amazing
good and it's like you know when you eat
something whether you like it or not
you know when you watch a movie whether
you like it or not you know when you
read a book whether you like it or not
but why don't we ask ourselves after
meeting people
completing projects or going to places
most of us keep meeting people that take
our energy most of us keep going to
places that drain us of our energy and
most of us keep working on projects
that just disturb our energy
all you have to do is ask yourself
does this bring me alive
why does it bring me alive really
important to know why it works and do i
want to do it again rule number seven
expand your emotional vocabulary i
really believe uh brendan that we have a
very limited emotional vocabulary so
when someone says we use five words okay
good
bad fine
right like how's your day going okay
how's your weekend good how's that
project fine right and so
we don't even understand how we feel so
how someone else can understand how we
feel so what the emotional vocabulary by
harvard does is that it shows you the
top word of say sad and then it shows
you almost
an extension of what are you really
feeling when you're sad are you upset
are you offended are you disappointed
are you disheartened are you heartbroken
there are so many more words so this is
what it means to think like a monk where
you diagnose
how you genuinely feel and then you
clearly articulate that so that not only
are you asking for the right thing
people really understand you and that's
one of the biggest mistakes in
relationships we we don't really know
what we're asking for rule number eight
entertain different ideas
psychologically we feel a sense of
safety and security
when we think people agree with us
right that is just psychologically true
that i we would rather avoid conflict
and sit in a space where we agree
and therefore we have something called
confirmation bias
and the echo chamber where we keep
surrounding ourselves with thoughts and
ideas that are similar and reaffirm our
beliefs
now i think that you can have that and
at the same time entertain ideas that
you're not sure about yet and so one of
my favorite examples was mit did this
study where they asked people
which person was more creative and
innovative and they showed two charts
one chart was employee a and the other
child was employee b
the chart for employee a
all of the people they knew
knew each other and knew them back so it
was almost like a closed loop and
employee b they knew lots of people who
didn't know each other
and they found that people who have more
people in their network who don't know
each other are more likely to be
creative and productive really yeah
because they expose you to opposing
ideas
and they may counteract how you think so
one of my favorite examples of this
is a conversation between
uh mark zuckerberg and one of his
mentors
so mark zuckerberg told this story
at the facebook headquarters a few years
back i wasn't there i've seen it on
video i'm sure it's available and he
talks about how when he was struggling
with the direction of facebook in 2009
he approached his mentor and his mentor
happened to be steve jobs wow pretty
cool wow pretty cool i wish really yeah
it's so cool man and so anyway so mark
zuckerberg goes to steve jobs and he
says i'm struggling with the direction
of facebook remember at that time
facebook was five years old there was no
fan pages i don't think i don't i don't
think it was there was no creators there
was i don't think they were fan pages it
was very much used by university
students at that stage like i think it
was mainly like ivy leagues
college kids and i don't even think it
was international in a massive way very
early days and now we can't even think
of that but 2009 i mean
you know you just about had the iphone
and just about had instagram youtube so
he ran up to steve jobs and he said
you know i'm struggling with the
direction of facebook what do i do
now steve jobs at that time obviously
was already
the founder of one of the biggest brands
on the planet and obviously the brand
still is
he had access to investors he had access
to business coaches i'm sure he had
access to life coaches he had access to
health experts everything he had access
to anything like i don't think there's
any scientists whatever scientists phds
i don't think there's anyone in the
world who steve jobs couldn't have
called up at the time
and steve jobs said something amazing he
said you know what mark i think you
should go
and live in an ashram in india he did
not he did oh
you guys and when you go to live in the
ashram in india
that's where if you spend some time
there that's where you'll find your
answer shut up and mark did it no way
went to the ashram this introduced quite
a lot i i believe he was there for i
believe i've seen two online i've seen
two versions of the exact time he was
there i've seen some people said it was
a couple of days or a week or some
people said it's a month so i think it's
it's hazy how much time he actually
spent there but but he went
and he says that based on that
experience that's where he found the
direction of facebook to be connecting
people
now the reason why i love that story is
because
it's the unobvious alternative random
connection and when harvard did a study
of 3 000 executives they looked at and
asked them what's the number one skill
for being a good leader
and a lot of people would say
communication a lot of people would say
vision strategy humility and the number
one answer that they got from 3000
executives
was the one word which is called
associating
and what that means is the ability to
spot patterns where everyone else
doesn't see them
and that's the connect that
real leaders can spot
patterns and connections in anomalies so
most people be like what is an ashram
got to do with a tech platform right but
that is where you expand your mind to
find answers that you never expected
rule number nine dedicate yourself to
the process i think in our limited
mindset sometimes we think that
detachment means indifference or
detachment means disconnecting
and actually detachment
means and i and i quote
um
this this incredible writer where he
said that
detachment doesn't mean that you own
nothing
detachment means that nothing owns you
and when you look at detachment through
that lens it means can i use everything
that i have
for a higher purpose can i use it and
engage it rather than be consumed and
used by it now granted that's a very
high platform to live on and it's not
easy but the point being that detachment
is not indifference that detachment
doesn't just mean oh i don't want
anything to do with this it's actually
how can i use this
for more than what it's being used for
right now and that's what's known as by
rupa goswami
he's
he quotes a about probably about 500
years ago
he created and coined a term called
yukta vairagya which means using
everything for a higher purpose
so he talks about how real renunciation
real detachment real aestheticism is how
can i use this for something more than
myself and it's not about just getting
rid of it i love that principle and i
think that that's a very
that's a very practical principle that
we can all employ living in the real
world so for monks detachment is real
like we didn't have beds right we didn't
have a place that we slept we slept in a
different place every night but if
you're not a monk and you want to apply
that same principle this is how you
think about it you recognize that i
don't want to be in a position where i
am consumed by everything another
addition to detachment is
detached from the result focused on the
process that's another definition in the
bhagavad-gita that you're not attached
to the fruits of your labor but you're
completely committed to the labor the
process itself
and that's something that we miss so
often that we think being detached means
not caring about what happens actually
it means caring about the process and
not caring about the result so when
we're talking about writing a book and
you know you've written books and when
you're writing a book
if you're writing a book and all you're
thinking about is how many copies am i
gonna sell
now you're not gonna write a good book
no you're dead out of the gate totally
you're dead straight away because all
you're thinking about how many copies am
i gonna sell is this gonna rank if
that's what you're thinking about you're
now not present which means you're not
to write a good job a good book whereas
if you were dedicated to the process
the result is a given the results are
natural end to dedicated to the process
annual number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is have
fun okay
wow there's so much choice
how does anyone decide what pasta tea
hey how's it going whereabouts is your
pasta
pasta
yeah
what are they called packed tomatoes
like boxes tomato boxes
that makes sense right oh here we go
chopped tomatoes strained not strained
do they have to be strained
i have no idea what to do
oh man should we just buy one of each
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you just get inspired you watch a
video you get motivated amazing
the science says you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something actually
following through that believe nation is
not enough that is not you not now not
anymore not today but when you get
inspired and then you create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do that number jumps to 91 chance of you
following through and when you commit
publicly to others like leaving a
comment in this video it jumps to 95
so the question of the day is your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and maybe next week i'll profile you
when we talk about
there's a beautiful statement by david
lynch who's movie producer and
deep meditator and he says that prayer
is how you talk to god and meditation is
how god talks to you
and whether you believe in god or the
universe or spirit or divine whatever it
means the point is that there is a
dialogue and a conversation prayer is
like you're speaking you're saying
here's what i want you know how i feel
yeah and meditation is more receiving
receiving yeah and so i love that
statement because i think it makes it
very clear that we have to have a
dialogue with the universe we have to
have a dialogue with people in our lives
we have to have a dialogue and there's
both giving and receiving so when i talk
about hearing in between the lines
the best example i can give you lewis is
let's take a look at you and your
relationship
and mine and my wife's relationship
one of us is always traveling yeah so
you travel your partner travels i travel
my wife travels sometimes we're missing
each other imagine you've got really
busy and hectic
do you think that anyone listening or
watching you'd ask the same question if
you were really busy and hectic and
stressed out
do you think your partner
feels comfortable
to tell you how they feel
and get your attention
uh if if i'm busy stressed out
overwhelmed will my partner tell me how
i feel about themselves or about yeah do
you think they would feel confident to
be like louis i need to tell you
something really important
um i don't think they would they
wouldn't yeah they really wouldn't
because they don't want to stress you
out they don't want to stress you you're
not presence all these things exactly so
exactly that and so what happens is
when you're still
your mind and body actually get to speak
to you and give you signals of how they
feel and so when you're still that's
when you notice that ache in your foot
that you haven't noticed for a month
sometimes when you slow down that's when
you get sick
because your body wasn't allowing itself
to be sick because you were pushing it
to get through stuff
and so just like your partners can't
communicate with you until you slow down
your body and mind can't communicate
with you until you still
and so there's a beautiful buddhist
teaching that says what movement does
for the body stillness does for the mind
and so when we find that space
stillness and solitude
you really are able to hear your deepest
desires and challenges
your physical pains and and areas of
growth it's one of the reasons why when
people meditate they feel sleepy
afterwards and they think they're doing
it wrong but actually they're doing it
right meditation just told you you
needed more sleep you needed to rest
yeah meditation was just a signal so
sometimes when i meditate with people
that i'm coaching it's like pass out
yeah some of them somebody will be like
i'm so sorry i'm i'm so sorry i'm just
feeling so tired and i'm like no then
sleep the rest yeah that's what your
body's telling you because you finally
listened and some people are like oh jay
i feel so energized and i'm like yeah
because you allowed yourself to be in
line with your body and know your body
saying that you feel energized at 18 i
was really fortunate when i met a monk
and this monk was invited to speak and i
kind of just went because one of my
friends forced me to at that time i was
listening to ceos and entrepreneurs and
business people and marketers who who i
thought that's what i was aspiring to be
like
and then i hear this monk
and he captivated me like no one had
ever captivated me before
it was like staring at the most
beautiful woman on the planet you know i
was completely fixated on him and his
message see we live in echo chambers
we're just surrounded by the same
thinking how often do you bump into a
monk you know it just doesn't happen you
don't have no one has a dinner party and
goes oh yeah we just invited the monk
you know from town like the local monk
like no one ever does that and so
we meet people who are just like us most
of the time
and we talk about this in business all
the time if you want to be a billionaire
spend time with billionaires if you want
to be a millionaire spend time with
millionaires if you want to be a tech
startup spend time with you know that's
that's the common rhetoric that we hear
all the time
but what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind
so so for me the first step is just
opening yourself up to new experiences
and new role models
because most of us can't see ourselves
in people so then we try and fit
ourselves into the boxes that we do see
and and i mean there's this beautiful
quote that i i've been saying it
everywhere and i wish i wrote it but i
didn't
so it's by a philosopher and writer
named cooley
and he said that today i'm not what i
think i am i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
right and just let that blow your mind
for a moment it's uh it's so powerful
i'm not what i think i am i'm not what
you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
so we live in this perception of a
perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think i should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks i should achieve
while you're living in that bubble in
that echo chamber
getting to what you really want to do is
impossible
because maybe that just doesn't fit and
i think so many people feel that way
today that they don't fit into the
current education system they don't fit
with the three or four or five careers
that you're taught exist
so that process of self-excavation and
actualization first requires being
exposed you can't be what you can't see
if i never saw a monk i would never have
wanted to be a monk if i never meet a
billionaire i wouldn't want to be one
because i wouldn't know what that feels
like i don't know what it looks like i
don't know what it takes and i think
that's the biggest challenge of our
society that we're not exposed so that's
the first step being exposed to unique
experiences and role models
second step is finding that experience
or role model that you're passionate
about and exactly like you said taking
it seriously shadow their network with
them spend time with them observe them
even from afar it takes that observation
being addicted to observing that
person's lifestyle
and then the third step is going yes or
no
does that work for me
not everyone who's going to go off and
become a monk is going to feel like the
way i did and that's cool
but not everyone is going to go and
follow and shadow a billionaire and go
that's exactly the lifestyle i want they
may want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step it's observing
focusing shadowing getting as close to
the process of that individual and then
going yes or no do i want that process
not do i want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through has an
incredible aura that people just
gravitate towards but when you realize
he has to wake up at 2 a.m every day and
sleeps about four to six hours you're
like ah you know i don't want to do it
that that doesn't sound like me how many
of you have a crazy dream or a crazy
goal i want you to write out in the
comments section what is your crazy
dream the dream that keeps you up at
night
is the real dream you should be chasing
but to chase that dream to find that
dream to make that dream a reality you
need a strategy right a dream without a
plan is just a wish tony robbins said
that right a dream without a plan is
just a wish
right without a strategy without a
guiding philosophy without guiding
principles without actually creating a
clear plan i used to have this economics
teacher and i want you to think back to
school as well maybe you had one i
remember this economics teacher you
walked in to the classroom
and the first thing that he wrote on the
board he didn't even tell us his name we
didn't even know who he was and he
turned up he went inside the classroom
and he wrote on the board he said
failing to prepare is preparing to fail
and all of us just burst out laughing
this guy hadn't even told us his name
yet but on the board he wrote failing to
prepare is preparing to fail
and now when i look back at that and as
i grew up and hopefully became a bit
more mature than i was in high school i
remember thinking about that statement
and thinking how true is that that when
you're not prepared for something you
miss out on unbelievable opportunities
now i'm not saying good things don't
happen spontaneously sometimes things
happen by chance randomly etc with a
reason but when you're prepared you can
capitalize on things in a huge huge way
play to your own element don't try and
perform someone else's expertly
so in modern terminology how would i say
that is
don't waste your time steve jobs don't
waste your time trying to live someone
else's life
you know don't be trapped by dogma
focus in on your own strengths your own
element what you have to offer don't get
lost in trying to become like someone
else or pretend to be someone else
there's a beautiful one of my favorite
quotes by einstein and then steve jobs
again einstein said if you judge a fish
by its ability to climb a tree it will
spend its whole life believing that it's
stupid
and too many of us are fish trying to
climb a tree too many of us are monkeys
being taught how to swim too many of us
are lions being taught to live like cats
we're not getting to live in our element
so my second piece of advice is live in
that element that you've naturally been
given don't try adopt another you know
we've all got a special genius inside of
us it was steve wozniak and steve jobs
this conversation steve wozniak looked
steve wozniak for those who don't know
is the tech guy behind apple he
practically invented the technology and
the software and everything so steve
wozniak looked at steve jobs and he says
this is in walter isaacson's biography
of steve jobs steve wasn't i wozniak
looks at steve jobs and he says what do
you even do
he said you're not a coder you're not a
designer you're not a marketer and
you're not an engineer what do you even
do imagine challenging steve jobs and
steve jobs replies he says
he says musicians play their instruments
i play the orchestra
that is the most deep understanding of
one's role in life and not getting lost
in other people's identities and
perceptions of you steve jobs knew that
he wasn't a marketer he wasn't an
engineer he wasn't a coder so he hired
all of those whether it's david beckham
taking one of his famous free kicks or
whether it's lewis hamilton winning the
formula one or whether it was steve jobs
about to give one of his famous keynotes
the most underrated skill was this
visualization the recreation of images
sounds and environments before it has
happened is one of the most powerful
skills in the world a very powerful
meditation and mindfulness practice
visualization has been used for
centuries to help prepare the mind the
body and the consciousness for upcoming
challenges situations and circumstances
some of the world's greatest athletes
use visualization as a way to prepare
for big games the big day musicians for
their new concerts and tours and ceos
for their very important meetings we
usually don't practice enough i realize
that if you really want to be good at
something you have to invest in it with
all your life you have to become
addicted and absorbed to improvement and
growth that means being open to feedback
that means being open to what the
experts have to say about you it means
not being attached to your ego and how
you feel about yourself but opening up
yourself to an expert group of people to
give you insight on how you can grow
evolve and perform at a higher rate and
link to that is practice practice
practice it's literally impossible to do
something perfectly the first time you
do it the more you do it the better you
get and we think practice is a cliche
that we hear all the time but actually
it's that truth it's so simple you might
miss it did i miss something here what
happens in societies that were clouded
by the noise the noise of
family expectations the noise of our
parents i grew up in a family where you
could either be a doctor a lawyer or a
failure those were my three options
anything else would just count me as a
failure right i'm standing up here in
front of you all as a failure we focus
so much on life in what we want to be as
opposed to who we want to be we've
always been told that life and jobs and
careers are like boxes and containers
there's only a finite number of options
you can decide right now that i don't
want to be defined by this box i don't
want to be defined by this container i
don't want to feel that if only i live
in this container then i'll be able to
be successful
fred smith was an undergraduate at yale
university in
1965. as part of his coursework he wrote
an economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the united
states it's how things get delivered to
you and me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages and items
either via truck or through passenger
airplanes he thought he had a more
efficient method he wrote a last-minute
paper as you do about how a company
transporting small items via plane would
be a much better business model because
he was rushed he never really got around
to explaining in the paper how that
company would run and he ended up
getting a c the funny thing is he still
didn't give up and in 1971 he actually
launched the company he was speaking
about but within three years of founding
the company federal express as it was
called was actually on the verge of
bankruptcy they were losing over a
million a month that was because of
rising fuel costs competitors in the
same market and at its zenith it was
only worth about five thousand dollars
smith even made a final pitch to general
dynamics hoping for more funding and was
rejected most people at this point
probably would have just shut down
rejection the grade c losing a million a
month but fred smith had different ideas
smith actually ended up flying to las
vegas that weekend with all of what the
company had the five thousand dollars
the monday morning after the company had
32 000 thanks to his blackjack skills
that money made it possible to cover
fuel costs for just a few days more soon
after the company was able to raise
significant funds he went around to
multiple places to find sponsors
investors people that believed in what
he was trying to achieve as a service
the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called fedex it now operates
in over 220 countries and has an annual
revenue of over 45 billion dollars the
interesting lesson that we can learn
here is that there were countless
occasions in fred smith's life where he
could have said that's it it's not
working for me he could have stopped
when he got that c for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just last a few more days but he
believed in his vision he had belief he
had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating and that's the lesson here if
you really want to achieve something
you'll find a way and if you don't
you'll find excuses i noticed in your
videos that you ask a lot of questions
and i i would imagine that's
an intense something that you intend to
do yeah i believe that
the answers come from within and we're
not asking the right questions i feel
we're always looking for the right
answers not the right questions and the
biggest companies that we respect today
the biggest organizations all came from
trying to answer a question it all came
from trying to solve a problem or a
question that we were able to identify
so
my work comes from a very simple study
that i read that said the most
successful people in the world choose
education over entertainment and the
most unsuccessful people in the world
choose entertainment over education with
their spare time so my mission has been
how do we spread
wisdom at the pace people want
entertainment and to me entertainment
allows you
to populate
the thought with your own brain like
when you watch a character or a
superhero you can watch it from your own
lens the movie may have morals you may
have values it may be somewhat good and
evil but the movie's not deciding for
you the movie allows you a space to
create and imagine and grow so for me
that's what i want my content to do is
give people a space to populate
themselves see themselves in the
characters that i'm presenting see their
own situation and be able to come to
their own conclusion so for me my three
e's are element environment and energy
everyone has an element that they thrive
in if you take someone out of it their
element they won't be the same a modern
day example would be michael jordan he
was incredible at basketball he took him
out of basketball put him in the
baseball no one remembers his career
we're talking about one of the best
athletes of all time
your environment is the environment
around you you can take a fish out of
water and give it a beautiful mansion
and a bentley and all the money in the
world but it would die
and that's what we are like our
environment everyone needs an
environment which they thrive which we
have to craft your boss if you're at
work is never going to ask you hey what
environment do you succeed in right like
that never happens so we have to create
an environment where we thrive and then
finally it's energy we some of us love
high energy environments high pressure
some of us succeed in low energy
environments and low pressure
figuring out your energy and the
frequency on which you operate best will
help you thrive as well so for me those
are the three e's to really create a
thriving environment know your element
know your environment and know your
energy and so at all times
if i see anything going wrong i'm going
is my element out of alignment is my
environment out of alignment or is my
energy out of alignment and that's a
great three question test you can do to
yourself when you don't think things are
going right and all you have to do is
bring that back into alignment i think
mark zuckerberg said it brilliantly at
harvard he was saying that finding your
purpose isn't enough you have to help
other people find theirs and i know
you're passionate about this
whatever that definition is but it has
to lead everyone so if i'm whether i
meet a celebrity an entrepreneur or
whether i meet someone who's starting
out i'm always asking them the question
how can you use what you have to make a
difference in the life of other people
yeah because if you start there
everything else will work out but if
you're starting from the point of what
am i going to get
then you're always going to feel
disconnected and i see that i see people
who live like that and feel pain in
their lives every day i see that it's
not like some conceptual philosophy we
see it i see people who are only in it
for themselves
and they feel disconnected dissatisfied
every single day
and then you see the other extreme where
people are just trying to give too much
more than they even have themselves and
they also feel disconnected
and again nothing at all they have
nothing at all right so we know again
attachment and aversion two sides of the
same coin
so we want to be in that dynamic balance
of growth but always to give yeah so i
always think how can i go three steps
deeper
so that i can move three steps forward
so i can give three times as much
right it's all that's always my
mentality how do i go deeper to go more
forward to give more yeah and if i can
get those three in action for that
reason see it's all about the reasoning
you can do anything you like but it's
why are you doing it
we all feel that rejection kills dreams
we all feel that failure kills dreams we
all feel that people kill dreams
you can't kill my dreams
but actually there's four words that we
say in our heads to ourselves that
genuinely have destroyed more dreams
than all of those things put together
those four words are
what will people say
what will people say how many times have
you stopped yourself from doing
something because you're scared of how
people will react how many times out of
the fear of someone else's opinion or
criticism have you stopped yourself from
doing what you believe in how many times
has someone's perception or perspective
stopped you from living your potential
no matter what you choose to do there
will always be people who find fault
with it there will always be people who
criticize complain and try to bring you
down and tell you that what you're doing
isn't right
haters gonna hate it's crazy that we
give up what we most want in life just
based on people's opinions and the crazy
thing is if we're living for other
people's opinions we'll never be right
there'll always be someone with
something that they won't agree with and
this is why it's so important that we
work with our own conviction we work on
what matters to us it was aristotle who
told us that there were only three ways
to avoid criticism do nothing say
nothing be nothing and i'm sure none of
us want that of our future when we die
our lifeline does this right it looks
like this
when you're living your lifeline's doing
this
notice how that connects with our real
experience of life
real life
is ups and downs
stagnant life death looks like this
being an entrepreneur looks like this
one's living one's dead you choose when
i saw that i started to visualize that
i realized that every time i failed
every time things went wrong every time
i chose to risk to live my passion and
things didn't work out and they don't
work out even now they don't work out
and when i analyze the lives of
entrepreneurs and look at how things
haven't worked out i just remind myself
that's living
that's not i'd like you to fast forward
to 70 80 90 years old
right fast forward in your mind to that
age 70 80 90 100 110 if you're really
optimistic whichever one it is and i'd
like you to write down
what will be the things that you'll
regret that you didn't do
imagine you're that age ask yourself the
question what will i regret that i
didn't do not what you did do but what
you didn't do
write it down make a long wrist right
now get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do it on your phone don't do
it on your laptop actually get a pen and
paper and write down your answers what
will be the things that you regret that
you didn't do
right really think about it would it be
you know learning a new language will it
be
moving home will it be
telling someone you love them what will
it be what would have been
write it down right now now the
incredible thing about this question is
that you're using the future to empower
the past whatever answer you have in
that
question whatever your answer is you can
do it right now today starting today
because you're not that agent and if
you're even if you're 64 and you're
tuning in 70 80 90 you're still there
right it's still possible you can start
doing that right now it's empowering the
present with the future there is nothing
stopping you
from making it happen right now you
don't have to feel that way when you're
70 you don't have to feel that way when
you're 18. you never ever have to feel
that way if you start doing it right now
and you can do it right now
even if it feels impossible you can
start working on it right now you can
start trying right now you can start
making plans right now because you're
not there yet
and this is where you start this is
where you start making it happen it's
all in the now ideal life for me is a
life and this applies to a company an
organization an institution for me
is an ideal life is when we all have a
head a heart and a hand all three
elements together working in alignment
without one or the other
we start to lose something if you only
have a head and a heart you'll find that
life is stable and defined yeah sure
sure sure
so ahead
is the clarity of vision
what you want what you want
knowing what you want the way you picked
your life and being able to navigate
make the decisions to get there that's a
good head
a good heart
is being able to understand what your
intuition and heart wants being able to
connect and tap into that understanding
deeper and beyond the vision you may
have painted for yourself so i often say
to people that you'll get to where you
want in life just not in the way you
imagined
and that's because
the path that's paved up and down
is far different to the path we pave so
you can have a great head and a great
vision and a great mission and know
where you want to go
but if your heart's not able to have
that resilience and be able to adapt
and and have compassion and care and all
of that then then you're not going to be
able to make the toughest decisions
without your heart but to be able to
realize that we need to
care and be sustainable and long-lasting
requires a heart and a hand is that
service
wanting to pass that on that which you
have wanting to give it forward pay it
forward the idea of serving with what
you have i often say to people your
passion is for you your purpose is for
others
your passion makes you happy but when
you use your passion to make a
difference in someone else's life that's
a service that's a purpose and that's
the hand
so those are my three
elements of an ideal life just around
two years ago i had this idea i wanted
to share wisdom at a pace we wanted
entertainment i wanted to share wisdom
in a way that it could connect resonate
and deeply evolve the lives of people
all over the world for 10 years before
that i've been working with individuals
groups coaching at universities
companies and all of these opportunities
but i really wanted to serve and connect
with everyone across the world i wanted
to make wisdom accessible to anyone who
had one of these i have one of those so
i was excited i had the energy the
enthusiasm and i was pitching my idea to
every single company that was online now
remember this is before i ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
i was who's this guy i applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea i waited a day
i waited two days away to the week i was
rejected by every single one of those
companies before interview none of them
invited me for a phone interview none of
them invited me for a video interview
none of them even connected with me in
any personal way that's rude
i said to myself it doesn't matter let's
see what else i can do to try and make
my goal a reality
so i tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance i got
one answer from one answer only they
said you're getting older now most of
the people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a master's and then
will take you seriously literally i was
getting rejected from every single
person i spoke to but inside of me i had
this desire i had this calling i had
this mission i had this vision that i
wanted to share everything that i'd
learned with people out there i
genuinely tried every single possible
method i could to break into the media
industry to the point that the only
thing that was left that i could try was
to start a social media channel and of
course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is that it reminds me
of a really powerful thought from thomas
edison he once said when you believe
you've exhausted all options remember
this you haven't that thought stayed in
my mind the whole time what i learned
from all of this rejection from all of
this failure from all of these clear
no's was one really important thing and
today i want to give that as a gift to
you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when i started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when i
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen that's when things started to
happen
this is nice
it's when i decided to take the
responsibility for sharing what i was
passionate about with the world and not
waiting for someone external to validate
me or give me permission or allow me to
do that
that's what made the difference if
you're feeling you've been going through
a lot of rejections ask yourself this is
your deeper passion and calling making
you want to move further number two have
you truly knocked on every single door
and number three are you working hard on
investing in your expertise and passion
so that you really have something
impactful to offer have you ever seen
someone successful or famous and thought
i could do that better than them so
what's the difference why is it that
they're out there achieving their goal
while you're not able to see people
underestimate the value of volume the
potential behind how many doors are you
ready to knock on how many tweets are
you willing to send how many people are
you willing to ask for help and ask for
their guidance and steers we hardly
achieve anything the first time we try
the people that have made it it's on
their 10th 20th 100th sometimes thousand
attempt so don't underestimate the power
of volume don't underestimate what's
possible when you go out there and speak
to everyone that you know one of the
things that
when things don't work out one of the
things i've been telling myself and also
thinking about a lot
is apart from the fact of learning which
we'll go into is just that space of
actually understanding
that there may be a different route see
we get so attached to having one route
one method one way of working we believe
that there's only one pathway to where
we want to be there's this conveyor belt
of things we have to do whether it's you
know get a degree find a partner buy a
house you know play golf whatever it is
like this conveyor belt of efficiency
and productivity that we hear that
becomes a part of our natural
progression
and when that breaks apart that's when
we start to worry that's when we start
to think but notice that
that actually it's a lot better when
that happens earlier in life see regret
has some really important roles the
first one is that it helps us make sense
of the world from our perspective for
one of the first time see most of us
have spent our lives
learning what's important to us based on
maybe what families thought what
community store what parents do what
education tour whatever it is when you
start regretting something when you
think you did something wrong when you
start thinking that i could have done
something differently you're making
sense of the world from your perspective
it's it's crazy how powerful this is
right you're starting to make sense of
the world from your perspective the
second thing is it allows you to avoid
future negative behavior if you knew you
regretted something i guarantee you
write it down right now right if you
regret something write it down right now
because it will teach you so much in the
future and you've got to write down the
lesson you learned now otherwise next
time when you think you're making
another tough decision you're going to
say to yourself oh what did i do last
time how did i not make myself regret
that and then you're going to be upset
you're going to regret that you didn't
write it down so write it down right now
if you're a musician serve if you're a
coder serve if you're a
orchestra leader serve if you're a
entrepreneur serve like make your life
about service and helping other people
not just to feel good but make that the
reason why you do what you do
don't make that what happens because you
have money make that the reason you do
what you do yeah and if people start
with service then you'll experience love
then you'll experience compassion then
you'll experience gratitude services
gandhi said that you find yourself when
you lose yourself in the service of
others
and and that's the deepest level of
self-actualization so know that you're
the soul and the consciousness not the
body
know that you have a unique genius and
don't settle for any less
and use both of those to serve
other people as the reason for the first
i remember this video that went viral
around two years ago where this young
girl around two years old started to
crawl and walk in her parents living
room she went up to the television
screen and she decided to try and get it
to swipe she started doing this with her
little hands and fingers hoping that the
television screen would swipe to her
complete bewilderment the television
screen did not swipe oh come on all of a
sudden tears started to run down her
eyes because she in her two-year-old
life had never come across a screen that
didn't swipe it doesn't work what do you
mean it doesn't work it doesn't work she
probably used her parents ipad or laptop
she used her parents screen and she'd
been seeing screen swipe for two years
but this screen did not swipe in two
years she had developed a belief that
every screen in her life
swipes imagine if in two years she was
completely conditioned to believe that
every screen swipes how quickly we all
become conditioned in two decades four
decades six decades or even more they
say that the biggest challenge today is
not simply to learn but to learn
unlearn and relearn wait what so i want
you to think about in your mind the one
habit that you want to change now if you
truly want to change your habit
psychologists and researchers say it
will take anywhere from 21 to 90 days if
you want to change anything in your life
you have to start with a small step but
make it a big priority one of the
biggest mistakes people make is they try
to make big changes and make them a
small priority i had it backwards albert
einstein famously remarked in a
conversation with werner heisenberg
he said you know in the west we've built
a beautiful ship and in it it has all
the comforts but actually the one thing
that it doesn't have is a compass and
that's why it doesn't know where it's
going this
paradise of our times was propounded by
the dalai lama when he said we have
wider freeways but narrower viewpoints
we have taller buildings but shorter
tempers will smith said that we spend
money we haven't earned on things we
don't need to impress people we don't
like
and it's phenomenal how the same
technology that brings us close to those
are far away takes us far away from the
people that are actually close 30
billion whatsapp messages are sent per
day but 48 of people say that they feel
lonelier in general the paradox of our
times is that we have
more degrees but less sense more
knowledge but less judgment more experts
but less solutions it was martin luther
king who said that the irony of our
times is that we have guided missiles
but misguided men have you ever found it
perplexing that we've been all the way
to the moon and back but we struggled to
start a conversation across the road or
across the train and it's amazing that
bill gates was known as the
top earner in 2015 with a wealth of 79.2
billion but one in four ceos claim to be
struggling from depression and do we
actually thrive off this paradox is it
that this paradox actually makes the
media interesting it's what makes
journalism interesting what makes
politics interesting is what makes
television interesting is this paradox
actually what we feed off and what we
live off and what we talk about and
discuss in our circles
doesn't it seem that we've tried to
clean the air but polluted our soul
we've split the atom but not our
prejudice and we're aiming for higher
incomes but we have lower morals so i'm
hearing you ask how do we bring a change
how do we
dissect this paradox that exists in our
lives and it starts by us each of us
pressing pause pressing reset and then
pressing play again taking a moment to
become more conscious taking a moment to
become more aware taking a moment to
really reflect on the consequence the
implications of a misplaced word of an
unnecessary argument that we all know we
didn't need to have or to
speak to someone just slightly
differently in a different tone and a
different voice in a different empathy
with a different perspective just to
really connect with people on a
different level
this thinking out loud started from
albert einstein and i'll track back to
him when he actually said that the
problems we have today can't be solved
with the same thinking we used when we
once created them so actually we need to
research alternative teachings we need
to deep down
dig into those ancient books of wisdom
we need to go back to understanding if
there's anything written in those crease
pages of time that can actually reveal
more knowledge and more wisdom of how we
can transform our experience of light
today otherwise this paradox
means that every step forward we take
we're taking three backwards every time
i believe that wealth is beautiful and
brilliant it can do incredible things in
the world when used to make a difference
when we use any wealth that we have to
make an impact to use it to make an
influence to help serve and support the
lives of others but today i want to talk
to you about a different type of rich
list there's more than one one of my
favorite teachings about wealth has been
this you can tell how rich you are by
counting the amount of things you have
that money cannot buy there's a
beautiful quote by jim carrey where he
says i believe that everyone should
become rich famous and achieve
everything they want just to realize
that it's not the point that would be
nice
real wealth inner wealth fulfillment
satisfaction meaning and purpose is a
rich list that every single one of us
can have and be on i want you to take a
moment to make a list of the things you
have that money cannot buy maybe it's a
beautiful family maybe it's an
incredible partner maybe it's a passion
and a drive that you've recently found
and discovered for yourself maybe it's a
recent experience that you had that
wasn't really about where you were but
more about who you were with and what
you were thinking about the reason why
i'm focusing on this rich list is
because this list is something we often
forget it's not on the front page of a
magazine it's not inside the newspapers
it's not on the list online but this
list is one that you can look at every
single day to remind yourself how
fortunate how grateful and how
incredible your life truly is so i quit
my job comfy corporate job doing really
well for myself and i'm trying to get
into media and so i'm writing to every
big media company with before my videos
and saying please give me a job like
i'll come in at like a video journalist
salary i was looking at salaries that
like a quarter of what i made i was like
i don't care about the money i want to
make videos and i want to spread a
message i'm getting rejection email
after rejection email saying jay you
never studied media jay you have no
background so i'm getting rejected by
all the biggest companies uh business
insider huff post the economist wired
you name it i've got all the emails
and then i try and network with the
editors of these magazines so i find out
where they are i go to the events i try
and talk to them and they're like to me
hey man you're like 28 years old why do
you want to do this you make more money
right now hang in the corporate world do
it as a hobby
i remember running after one of our
biggest news anchors in england called
jon snow
and he rides a biker in london but he's
like he's huge he's on channel 4 one of
the biggest broadcasters for us and so i
run after him when he's on his bike and
i'm like john please please stop and he
stops he's really kind i said john can
you please give me a job i'll just i
don't even want to get paid i'll just
watch you and i because he creates these
powerful documentaries he's interviewed
the best of the best like mandela and
all this stuff life-changing
conversations
and he goes to me he gives me a card and
he goes jay go get a masters in media
and then come back
and i'm thinking
i'll spend two three more years yeah
exactly i'm gonna go back like
anyway so i came to a point
where i literally had no other option
than to start a youtube channel
and and my honest limiting belief at the
time was that doesn't work for anyone
and that's what i said to myself it's
not gonna work for anyone but i
literally had exhausted i think it's
thomas edison who says when you feel
you've exhausted every option remember
you haven't
and i'd come to that point where i felt
i'd exhausted every option apart from
starting a youtube channel
so i launched the channel jan 3rd 2016
two years ago
and it's doing pretty well flow or flow
state is defined as the optimal state of
consciousness when we perform at our
best feel at our best but also at the
same time ego falls away time flies
we're conscious but subconsciously
experiencing our own art it's when we're
fully immersed absorbed and addicted to
simply creating now i'm sure you've all
had moments when you felt that whether
you've been playing sports an instrument
traveling maybe looking at a beautiful
scenic view or maybe just in a really
engaging conversation but i'm going to
share with you how we can experience
more flow in our lives because it
heightens our sense of joy or curiosity
so the two variables of flow are
challenge and ability and flow is where
challenge and ability collide or meet
if your answer to my question earlier is
that you often feel bored it's usually
because your skills are higher than your
challenge everything seems easy it's not
exciting anymore there's nothing new you
need to learn and you feel like you can
do things effortlessly but not in a way
that excites you or empowers you but in
a way that almost drains you and makes
you feel more lethargic and lazy i'm
bored
but let's say you're feeling more
stressed let's say you're feeling
anxious let's say you get nervous often
that's usually because the challenge is
greater than our skill the challenge has
become so high it feels like this
massive mountain that we're trying to
climb and we feel like we're completely
carrying the biggest weight on our
shoulders and therefore we're feeling
the pressure feeling the strain feeling
that stress in each of these scenarios
what you're seeing is a disconnect
between your challenge and your ability
which is either causing stress or
boredom and there's a really really
simple solution if you're feeling bored
because your skills are higher than your
challenge what you need to do to make
life abundant exciting thrilling again
is raise your challenge try new
opportunities go into new arenas be in
new environments meet new people what
that will force you to do is make you
raise your challenge which allow you to
grow allow you to thrive and if you're
finding that what you experience more
often than not is stress it's pressure
is pain then the way you combat that is
by increasing your skill level try going
on online courses learn from mentors go
on an apprenticeship see who you can
learn and be coached by and guided by to
improve your skills what that will help
you do is meet your challenge with a
higher skill set you'll now be able to
walk into a challenge with confidence
that you'll know how to navigate the
various things the challenge will bring
into your life flow state is this
beautiful space where we completely
surrender to the art and allow the
energy to truly flow through us it's
something i've personally experienced
and want you to experience in your life
as well
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there